ses parents d'élèves manifestent contre
des cours d'éducation sexuelle donné à
des enfants en Belgique huit écoles ont
été vandalisées et incendies en cause
c'est ce nouveau guide à l'attention des
enseignants rédigé en écriture inclusive
et dit non hétéro normative au programme
identité de genre non désirs d'enfants
ou encore GPA car depuis le 7 septembre
la région francophone de Belgique à
l'obligation d'organiser des cours
d'éducation sexuelle et affective dès
l'âge de 11 ans pour les moins de 11 ans
ils sont facultatifs concrètement ce
guide doit apporter des réponses aux
questionnements des élèves il aborde de
nombreux thèmes tels que les identités
et expressions de genre les violences
les comportements sexuels ou encore le
corps et le développement humain des
grandes thématiques qui sont adaptées à
chaque tranche d'âge par exemple les
séances dédiées au 91 ans peuvent
évoquer les modèles positifs
lgbtqia+ ou encore les intersectations
toujours pour les 9 11 ans il propose de
parler du plaisir et de la sexualité le
thème du désir ou du non désir d'avoir
des enfants peut aussi être abordés
durant les séances le professeur doit
ainsi parler de la parentalité ou de la
pression sociale il invite également à
initier les enfants à la diversité des
moyens d'avoir ou une enfant en tout 85
000 élèves en Wallonie et 25000 élèves à
Bruxelles sont concernés 8 écoles ont
été vandalisées ou incendiés dans le
pays dont quatre à Charleroi conduisant
la justice belge à ouvrir une enquête
pour incendie criminelle des actions
revendiquées par le mouvement no evras
dimanche 1500 personnes se sont réunies
aux alentours de la gare centrale
bruxellesoise on y retrouve notamment
des personnes issues de la communauté
musulmane et des militants catholiques
ainsi que l'association internationale
innocence en danger qui a pour objectif
de protéger les enfants contre toute
forme de violence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]